hi there it's Kevin Van Ord standing in
for reviewer Jason Venter to tell you
about nes remix - nes remix was a good
idea when it launched in late 2013 and
reintroduced players to some of the
greatest gaming moments from the 8-bit
era nes remix - improves upon the first
by boasting a superior roster of games
fragments of 10 key Nintendo
Entertainment System games are included
starting with Super Mario Brothers 3
which is available to sample immediately
once you complete a challenge or two and
earn some stars you gain access to dr.
Mario Super Mario Brothers 2 and a few
others earn more stars and you unlock
more challenges from other games these
challenges feature bite-sized samples of
popular NES games that assign you
specific tasks a challenge might put you
in links shoes and have you navigate a
perilous series of ledges or it might
have you tossing pills at moving viruses
as dr. Mario however the most
interesting of them combined elements
from multiple series and the unexpected
twists that result if the challenge is
fresh for instance link might need to
hack his way through bricks to collect
coins in the Mushroom Kingdom that Mario
would snag in a hurry or pit from Kid
Icarus might have to try to collect
fairies while avoiding flying ghosts in
an environment that was ripped from
links adventure other remix activities
present fun twists that don't require
franchise fusion for instance Mario will
be running full speed and you simply
have to choose when to jump and with how
much vigor there's only one game here
you can explore in full which is a
reworked version of super mario brothers
called super luigi brothers here you
play as Luigi instead of Mario and the
screen Scrolls from right to left
instead of left to right the less famous
sibling slides and skids like socks on
linoleum but he jumps higher and further
as compensation when combined with the
unconventional orientation the altered
physics make a strange experience out of
familiar terrain muscle memory and
time-worn technique are no longer your
allies they're more likely to land you
in a pit or send you flying
headfirst into a patrolling Goomba nes
remix - sometimes feels like the world's
greatest marketing ploy and not a
distinct new experience there's even a
handy link to the eShop which
conveniently sells full versions of each
excerpted title a fair number of the
objectives provide an overview of their
game's most iconic hooks and gameplay
mechanics which is enough to whet your
appetite but not wholly satisfy it one
challenge involves watching the Wario's
woods opening tutorial for instance and
another screens a training montage from
punch-out the ending sequences for the
various games are also shown meaning
it's a good idea to finish them ahead of
time if you are saving such things for a
surprise nes remix - maybe a highlights
reel that you pay for but that's no bad
thing if you're interested in
challenging yourself while you
reminiscence ample old conventions have
been modified to offer enough variety
and genuinely interesting challenges
that they manage to prove interesting
all over again
you